Speakers. And we will now be
going to the City Council. Yeah, one of
the, I would say being biased, one of the best departments.
So at this time, I want to welcome Ms. Bernita Jones
to provide the administrative office of City Council budget presentation
and shout out to her whole new staff because she has a new
staff with a lot of friendly and new faces.
So thank you all for being here. Look forward to your presentation.
It. Welcome, Miss Jones. And the floor is yours.
Oh, all right, thank you. Get a
break.
That's a R.
Thank you. Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Bernita Jones. I'm assistant director for
Houston City Council. And today I will be presenting the
FY 23 projected budget for City Council. But before
I start, I would like to introduce my staff to you.
On my right I have Mary Hamilton. He does the financial analyst
for City Council. And if my new staff will please stand,
I would like to acknowledge them. These are the individuals that
take care of city council every day. They make sure that
all of their needs are met. They work really hard and they
always have a smile on their face regardless of what's going on. And I would
just like to thank them. I appreciate each one of them.
Next slide, please.
Right here are 16 council members
that are overlooking the beautiful city of Houston,
Texas. And I would like to acknowledge
the council members because every Tuesday
constituents come in and they just
hammer the mayor and the council member. And I would like to say that these
City council member works very hard. They work hard and they're
diligently looking after the city. They have CIP
meetings, they have civic club meetings that they attend. They have
town hall meetings. And they do a great job in making sure that the
City of Houston is the best that it can be. And I thank each council
member for the hard work that you do. Thank you. Next slide,
please. Okay,
now this is the organizational chart for the City of Houston.
And in FY 22 we
had approximately 78.4 I
can't see the screen 78.4 FTEs.
In FY 23, we're proposing to have
79.5 FTEs.
And as you can see, the budget for FY 23 is proposed to
be $13,985,308
for City Council as a whole. The budget
as you go down, you will see, will be split between 16 council members and
that would be $491,115.
A little
further, you go down and you see city council general. That's $627,466
which is allocated for the health funds and the health insurance
for city council members and their staff. The last allocation
is for council district service funds. That's $5,500,000.
Next slide, please.
Next. We have the gender and the ethnicity, the demographics
for City Council. There are 53 females
and 26 males that's working with City Council.
And ethnicity. We have 29 white, 29 black African
American, 18 Hispanic Latinos and three Asian
Pacific Islanders. Next slide, please.
And right here I'm going to do a comparison and I really want
to break it down because I want to make sure that we're open and
everybody understand exactly how city council budget works. So I
tried to break it down a little further on this slide to kind of explain
exactly how it is. Our adopted budget in FY
22 was $13,604,307,
and that was
split between the office at $468,915.
So as you can see, the FY 22 operating budget was $7,502,640.
This is the money that council members use to pay
their staff for services and for office supplies.
It all of this comes from their operating budget.
So you make sure you understand that's what that is for. Then you have the
council district service fund, which is 5,500,000,
and the health benefits that I told you about earlier,
that is how we comprise of 13,604,317.
If you were to look at the budget book today, you will see that council's
budget seems to have increased, but it has not.
Literally, it hasn't. It is 15,000,508 $193
as of today. And the reason for that, as you can see, we had
restricted accounts, a credit of 5609.
We had a Hope adjustment of 3%, and that was 130,480.
And then we had a
council district fund carry forward over
of $1,779,005.
I want to explain the carry forward for you in case some people
may not understand what this is. In FY 21,
all of the council funds and the projects that were requested.
As you know, sometimes it takes a lot
to get these done, and I want everybody to know that the council members work
diligently. We have a process. First of all, it has to be reviewed
by legal and then the administration has to approve
it. So sometimes it takes a little longer for these projects
to go into fruition. So if the project has been reviewed
by legal and it has been approved by the administration,
but we have not purchased the items yet or they have not completed
it, those funds can be rolled and forwarded and carried
over. So that's why you have a carry forward of 1,000,007, seven,
nine, five. And that is why the budget looks like it increased at
the present day. Next slide, please.
So for now, we are projecting to have $13,985,308
in city council's budget, and that comprises again
of the operating budget,
$7,857,842.
Council district service fund,
5,500,000, and health benefits,
$627,466.
Next slide, please.
These are the It. As I stated before that a
lot of times it seems as if the budget is big, but council
member budget is mainly staff and driven
by it. That is why these are here to show you
some of the It driven costs that you will have application services
increased by 30,657. And any
hits questions, I would ask that you would direct that to hits, because these
are the numbers that I received from the It department.
Data services decreased by $11,283.
Voice services decreased by $3,244.
Voice labors decreased by $509. Next slide
please. Egis revolving fund service decreased
by $25. Voice Services wireless increased by $3,192.
Chronos chargeback increased $247.
Next slide please. Overall you
can see as I stated early,
91.39% of city
council's budget is allocated to personnel. And then
you have 7.28% which is in other services and charges.
And out of the services and charges,
78% is hits related charges,
1.29% is supplies, and then you have 0.4%
for equipment. Next slide please.
So this is Council District Service Fund. Carry forward over from FY 21.
As I stated before, there's 1,779,000
worth of council district service funds that we had to carry
over that were not completed in FY 21.
We are proposing what we adopted 5,500,000
for FY 22. As of today, we don't know how
much will be carried forward to FY 23. We will know that amount
on June 30. When the fiscal year ends,
we are projecting to get another 5,500,000 in council
district service Fund for FY 23.
Next slide please.
Right here are major projects, and I just want everybody to
know that we have approximately 350
to 400 council district service projects
that are performed annually with this money. And on here,
I just basically put the major projects,
projects that are very expensive and
a lot of funding is needed for these. So they have increased from
last year. As far as major projects. On these two pages you can go
through and see all of the major projects that the council members are doing.
And as I stated, these projects are
really important things to the city. That's why
I say these council members are working hard. We go through legal.
I know there's been a lot of talk about council district service funds,
but legal reviews them, the administration approves
it. We make sure that all contracts are
accurate before we do any work with any of these major projects
or any projects. Next slide please.
This is a slide of the priorities and
initiatives that the council members have stated are their top two.
These are the top two, they have several, but this shows
by district which initiatives they have stated to be priorities,
initiative as their top two. And the next page shows
the at large council district service funds, council district
members. These are their priorities and their initiatives.
Next slide please.
Looking at this, you can see that $4,743,915
are allocated to HPW, that is the council district's
service fund, and it is broken down based on how much money we allocated
in FY 22 for these projects.
So HPW and HPD are the most ones that
council district service funds are allocated to. Next slide please.
Appendix and then in the appendix we have the restricted
accounts, because as I stated, hits restricted accounts really
has a major important part in the council members budget.
Thank you for your attention. Are there any questions for me at this time?
That was such a great presentation. You do an excellent job,
you and your entire staff. Thank you.
Council member Cayman.
Ms. V, thank you for everything. You're welcome.
And to the new staff, welcome. We're so happy
to have you. And, of course, Miss Love, thank you for always being
there. You do so
much for our offices, from our budget meetings
to, again, tracking, I think you said over 400
projects that we're each pushing through all
of the time. So, again, huge appreciation
to your office in terms of needs that you see either for
your office specifically or as council,
what do you foresee in the coming future as some of those
needs? So I have conferred with several of the
council members, and I do know that they are short
staffed and the needs that they have in their office,
if they could have more staff members, because right now
they are stretched pretty wide based on all of the work that's
going on in their offices. And there are minimum four to
five staff members in every office, and the need to have
more people in their office would be great. And I've always said
that the council district service fund is great, and they've asked for more
because they can't complete all of their projects because they're kind
of waiting toward the end because they don't have enough money to do all the
things that the constituents are asking for. I certainly
echo the need for more staff, I think our
council staff and a huge thank you to all of our council staff.
We did a tally in a poll of our district,
most, of course, per usual three one one calls, but also most calls
of a district office. I don't know how my staff does it, but they're incredible.
And we could always I think I speak for every at least
district office of we could always use and at large. Okay. And at
large, we can always use more. Just so,
Ms. Vernita, for the public's knowledge,
the council members, our salaries are
not set by the city, is that correct? Yes. Your salary
is based on the judges at the county. And in
terms of I mean, we're covered by insurance and things like that.
But as council members, we don't have things
like FMLA, is that correct? That is correct. But we were
able to get, at least for our chiefs of staff that had an exception previously,
coverage for paid parental leave and other benefits.
That is correct. Okay. I just wanted that to be clear. Thank you. Okay,
thank you. Council Member
David Robinson. Yeah. And just to build on that question,
the recent Hope adjustment, ms.
Jones, if you could comment on that, how that affected the salaries of our
staff and for that matter, council members, if you could.
I'm sorry. The hope, the city employment,
the home contract yes. And what was the question,
if you could state out loud for the record how that affected our
staff and our personal salaries. So what happens is the
increase is 3% and it is based on an average of the
council members in their office. And because council members
have to have the same budget, we average out the highest office
and whatever that is times 3%, that is determined
how we allocate the 3% and that increases everybody's budget
the same. Thank you. But the council members do
not get a 3%, right? Correct. That's what
I wanted to hear. Thank you.
Well, thank you again for your presentation. Thank you to your entire staff.
We lean on you all for so much and
kind of the backbone of our offices, which are extension of
all of our constituents in each district and at large. So thank
you again and you are dismissed. Thank you.
We will now move on to the public comment period.
We will start with the virtual public speakers. Please press star
six to unmute when your name is called and
the first name is ms. Saba Blandy.
Good afternoon again. I had
a question, a couple I was curious, what is
one piece of information you would most like to know
if you were able to survey every single one of your constituents
and what do you think are the most effective efforts to engage
your constituents in your district? And I'm just curious
if anyone has some new efforts planned for the coming year?
Okay, I'm going to ask you, Ms. Blanding, to repeat that a little slower one
more time. Oh, man, I'm sorry, Councilman Member
Pollard, I was trying to go slower. Okay. I was curious
what one piece of information you would most like to know
if you were able to survey every single one of your constituents?
I was also curious what you think are the most effective efforts to engage
your constituents in your districts. And I was also curious what
are some new efforts planned for the coming year?
Okay, so for my office, and I know for everyone,
it's probably different, but one piece of information I would like to know is
how they feel about our constituent response times when
they reach out to our office, either by telephone or email.
Do they feel as if their issues and concerns are being addressed
promptly? I think the best way to engage the
constituents is by showing up in person, whether that's an HOA or a civic
club. But people like to see you active and in person.
I think it's a great way to develop relationships and also a great way
in which to communicate and understand their needs from the
grassroots level.
Anyone else in the horse you want to chime in?
And your third question, Ms. Blanding.
I was just curious if anyone had some new efforts they wanted to try this
year in terms of engaging constituents.
If anyone had some new ideas, what ideas
do you have?
Oh, well, I mean, I always think efforts
to to provide surveys are good, and I know traditionally there's
club engagement, but as much as I can engage here,
civic club, my husband has a meeting every month for
our civic club. So I was just curious what you all like to
try. I think most of us like to get a lot of our ideas from
the public. We really work for you. So many of the times that
you see us responding to issues or concerns is based
on your engagement. So it
would be great to hear from you as a constituent, what ways
in which you think we can better communicate and collaborate
with you and the community. So if you
have an idea or something you would like to share, maybe even not today,
but feel free to email us if you have ideas on ways in
which we can best communicate and engage with you going forward.
Absolutely. I appreciate the invitation. You're welcome. The next speaker,
Ms. Barbara Herndon.
Barbara Herndon, please press star six to unmute.
Amanda Shy, please press star six to unmute.
Hi, and just briefly, my last name is she.
Thank you. Thank you for your time today.
So many of the other departments
have metrics or outcomes outlined in the budgets that they
publish. So as representatives of constituents, do you
all have target metrics? What do you consider outcomes?
And then I have another thought, which is
that the slide 15 in terms of the distribution of the CDSF
funds, that was really helpful. As a constituent
of District I, I would just like to express that I'm interested in
seeing more funds allocated for Case Education, Do,
N, and HPL, all departments and programs that
have expressed unmet needs throughout these presentations.
So I'll return to my question, which is basically,
what are some target metrics and outcomes that
you all have in mind?
So as it pertains to metrics, I can speak for the District J office.
What we like to do is put out initiatives and projects and ideas
that we have many times that are brand new, and then we have to
wait and see what the outcomes are. We're really a results based
office. And so whether it's with supplemental trash or
a District J Patrol program, new initiatives that are
just now coming to the district, many times it's going to be
based off the feedback, the engagement, how many people are receptive,
and responsive to the things that we're doing, the feedback that we
hear at the civic clubs and the HOA meetings on if it's beneficial
or not. Do they believe it's something that they want
to see their tax dollars spent on? And for most of us, I think
that's how we are able to gauge if a project is worthwhile
going into the next budget year to fund through our council district
service funds going forward.
And was there one other question that you may have had.
That was my main question. Do any of the other council members
want to share?
None at the moment, because I think we're running behind on
time. But I'm sure if you reach out to your individual
district council member, they will collaborate with you going forward.
But thank you for your questions. Next is Jason Oliver.
All right, if you'll indulge me, I want to start off just by really
I really appreciate CDSF and these presentations because I
know that you all create a lot of these programs directly
in response to what community members are asking for. So some of
the ones I'm excited about and glad to see, a lot of the trash pickup
and drainage work, the Senior Development Boys
and Girls Club and District K, the Public
Safety, the more expansive public safety, street lights and
sidewalks stuff happening in District F, seeing some of the
Vision Zero. And then the WiFi
access is huge in District H,
there's a lot. And then the community beautification work
that's happening in district, just some of the ones that kind of stuck out to
me that I really wanted to highlight. And now to go into
my questions. So first,
where are we in terms of the impartment inspection reform? Just curious
about that project that I know we've heard about over the years. And then
second, does any district and this goes into Council Member Pollard's
question about engagement with constituents.
Does any district have good resources or processes explaining
how the CDSF works to constituents,
explaining how it works, what projects are proposed and eligible,
and the process for submission? I think CDSF is a huge
opportunity to widen the net of how people know
about what the district is doing and then really getting engaged in that
process of directly participating there. So, yeah,
that's my idea for engagement. So regarding
the apartment inspection ordinance,
that is something that's pending at the moment. I know that Council Member Leticia Plumber
is taking the lead on that. And so those discussions are
still ongoing on the best considerations
for that as it pertains to the council district service funds.
Many times what we do is we reach out to all of our neighborhood associations
and stakeholders within the community and ask them what do they like
to see regarding if it's improved parks,
if it's improved infrastructure, do they want to see more police
presence? So every community and district is unique
and has its own dynamics. And so many times the requests
that come into our office for things that they want to see, we prioritize.
And then those are what we spend the dollars on through our council's funds.
Council Member Cayman Jason, to your question about outreach
in terms of determining some CDSF, I know multiple council members,
including my office, have started even doing surveys
on social media. So, for example, we fund air monitors that
are publicly accessible information. But where they should go up we
put a survey out, we ask for suggestions, and the locations
are being determined based on that. I think it's a whole combination of things.
Council member newsletters always open to more information,
but you are asking some really important questions.
They're directed, I think, to all of us. But I think the best way to
get some of those responses or provide your suggestions is to individually
reach out on that and also know that we
leverage a lot of our dollars. So even though we get a
million dollars, 500 for mobility and
then 500 for just general operating projects
in our district, we leverage that money with the management
districts, with our Turs, with our county partners. So we try to
find outside dollars, even from the private sector to partner
with. So we may be able to turn $100,000
allocation into a $400,000 allocation just by working with other
entities that have similar interests in what we're trying
to do. So we appreciate all the
constituents feedback on ways in which we spend
your tax dollars. And if there's particular projects and initiatives
that you see in your community that you like and you want to advocate
for going forward, please do. And if there are things that you don't like or
that you think are not beneficial that we're spending your tax dollars on, let us
know that as well. And that completes our public
comment period for the City Council presentations.
And now we will move on to
welcome director Tina Pius and Valerie Berry to
provide the And Regulatory Affairs budget presentation.